Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and
welcome back to Subnautica
and GOOD MORNING AUROURA!!!!
How u doin'?
Oh still dead?
oh that's so sad
I'm alone here
I have no friends left (like dis if u cry every time)
They're all dead
Ha HA hahaha
Anyway welcome back to Subnautica (again)
So we were in bit of a crisis last time
and I rushed away from that crash site
Because I was dying
I know I left a lot of things
Number one I left a PDA
But number two I left the
Vehicle Modification Station
which I can only assume is now the new name for the
Seamoth Modification Station
which is what I need
to put in the moon pool
to be able to make
what I need to make
but before that I'm about to die
so i have to go into the
into the uh
into the escape pod of lag now
and then I gotta go ooohh god
(Marki moans)
oh my god
Ohhh my god (the lag is real)
I need to make
(Inhale)
Ahhh god dammit
I got table coral and not that coral and I need to make water
Oh my god
It's so laggy
I have no idea why
(A nice inhale)
But also need to make food
I need to drink water
I have to take care of myself
I need to hydrate
I got table coral and not the right coral
But at least y'know I'm gonna make that gosh darn computer chip (Mmm chips)
Then I'm gonna go get some
Oh I make an advanced wiring kit
I probably need
NO
I needed the computer chip
Fuuuuuck
Ok god dammit I'll be back
Fuuck
Y'know let's (x3)
Pull a [?muligan?] on the begining of this video
I'm gonna as...
Let's all assume
That this isn't the beginning
And let's just skirt on forward the actual beginning, huh?
(The screams of the children in marks basement)
Uh? Why are you green
Woah.
WOAH. (x2)
WOAH!? (x3)
It was GREEN! (Okay Mark take it easy.)
Is that the effect of the virus (Probably)
NO WAY
It's GREEN (you already said it)
Holy 💩 it's green
that legitimately means-
I'm pretty sure that's legitimately...
the virus having its way with
these (X2) uh
the fauna here, OH MY GOD they're GREEN TOO
everything's dying... (; - ;) I should probably...
DO something about that. OR NOT at the beginning of the
episode yet *Mark commands* EVERBODY GO BACK
IT'S NOT TIME
DINNER'S NOT READY (alrighty then)
DON'T COME INTO THE KITCHEN
WHEN MOMMY'S (Mommiplier) COOKING
Is Markiplier losing his mind in the deep ocean? (Maybe)
The answer is *Stares into souls of viewers* YES
Excessively.
HAHAHA LOL (X3)
Now that everyone knows I'm absolutely out of my gourd
*Breaths*
Hello (again) Welcome back to Subnautica (again)
so right now we're going to go back to
the wreck by the Mushroom (Kingdom?) Forest
and We're going to collect
what BELONGS to US
and what BELONGS to US is one more PDA
little bit more story in it
and then another design for the rest of the
Vehicle Modification Station which is
something that I absolutely, YES
100% NEED
and if I don't *cube flies at ship* have that-
WTF was that
Excuse me
WTF is that? (It looks like a cube Mark)
OH! oh I forgot I dumped that!
because I needed some GOODIES, oh ok
We-hehe-ll WHOOPS found THAT again
how in- what are the odds of me finding that
one thing that I dumped (small)
Oh well
*CRASH* Ah. Fucking god dammit
Fuck Off with your Fucking Fucker (fuck and derivatives count: 100.000.000)
OH YEAH I forgot, I've got names to read
I don't have lockers yet
because I don't have the, uh-
I don't have the new base built
but I've got Names so
Phantom said "If you make a Seamoth
Perimeter Defensive System- Which sounds fucking awesome
-it's easier to get past the Reaper Leviathan
it activates when they try to grabble the ship
*Mark acting it out* It will SHOCK 'em and then
they'll let go." so that's pretty cool but I have
no idea how to make that, uh, The General said "Sorry
there's no way to deactivate the gun yet
no matter what the sunbeam gets shot down like
me whenever I flirt with a girl (aw sorry about that)
at least the sun chick beam getting shot down looks cool"
So I'm going to put the General, once I do get my base
back, that comment is fricking amazing
and hilarious and I love it uh but I'm not gonna
be able to get to that till I beat it
until I get that just soon
SOO hopefully
*whispers* there's none right near me
and then Abby Necko who said "I missed a PDA
of the crash site" so thank you for that
*whispers* "I wouldn't have known" OH well Handy that
WELL would you look at zhat I've got the Vehicle
Modification Station. (yey)
well that's good for me.
so I'm just gonna sneak in here real quick
because I did *Warning Maximum Depth*
miss the PDA
so I'm gonna try *Mark ignores Karen*
AHH Fuck well Fuck
*Warning again*
Thanks Karen I know take care of it I know it's a
TIGHT SQUEEZE but squeeze into it YOU MUST
Ok so their was apparently
a PDA around here somewhere that I darn missed
UH I think you're MISSING the HANDLE just a little bit
there buddy OOOH hohoho secret double DOOR
who would've known
ahh this abandoned PDA profitability projections
WE-HEHE-LL I'm sure there's a lot of goodies here
but I'm also sure there's a lot of deadies here (say what)
as in crew members and family members (Oh) and...
Everyone else there all-
Yish. they're all quite DEAD
Ok
SABUSKEY Ok (again) I got what I needed their so...
Now that I got that
I'm all good, I've got what I needed, I got what I came for
I'm going to read the PDA entry on the way back and then
I'm gonna cut forward to when I've already
got the materials for my base, I'm not going to make you wait
any longer on that one then I'm going to go get the materials (already said that)
and then get to the point where I'm ready
to make my new base sound GOOD alright we'll do that.
Oh shoot we got an- Uh oh
I think I know what that one's all about
Uh...
I think I know- alright anyway
*Reading the PDA* "Two choices A) Carry on working
long-haul missions on the outer reaches of space B) come up with a
profitable business, sell out to Alterra
Live happily ever after. I choose B
Ideas: A robot that build other robots
A laser cutter that has infinite battery life (solar power?)
A phase gate that can be built by self-repeating robots
instead of poor lonely humans on an 18 month mission
A VR program that precisely simulates real life down to the
finest detail how do I know that they didn't already invent it
and we're inside it right now? A gun that shoots
other, smaller guns" Uh thoose are
those are FANTASTIC ideas (Indeed I agree more with the gun that shoots smaller guns) I LOVE that
Ok I'll be right back WOOAHU (what is this Mario?)
Ow WOAH my god OW my ASS
KAREN Jesus I told you to ask PERMISSION first.
Oh boy, oh boy
*Communication Relay*
Yeah that's a BAD idea ('cause of the giant alien gun) don't do that. Ooh boy
They're all dead aren't they? they are going to be very DEAD
DON'T GO NOWHERE
Okay I GOT IT
HAYABDA (Da fuk wuz that Mark?)
K gotta to deploy this *grunts* OH MY GOOOD
DEPLOY!!!!
HAB- HA- Ugh I NEVER DEPLOYED YOU!!!
BEEEH- Ok UUh shit. Oh that's so COOL I'm going to call you "The General" (because of the guy from before remember?)
Th-The Generl (lel) ah I like it. Okay where did all my titanium go?
EEH I do NOOT like being in this god damn creep vine forest
HOOOAHA HEHEHEHEA *the sounds of the Markimoo*
Yeah it sucks Oh YEAH I like the way this SUCKS😏
*singing* Making some LuuuuBE  making some LUUBE
Making a whole lot of LUUUBE
Ok what the hell happened MY- THIS MOVED AGAIN
I'm never going to Be able to find The Generl you MOVED
why did you move? ; - ; why are you moving so much?
You ass!
You bag of ass dicks.
You bag of butt hole douches!
YOU BAG OF BINGLE BONGERS!!
you bag of duchel dongers.
Ok.
but either way I have Four (not 3 not 11, 4) ingots
I have six titaniUMS
I have FUUD I'm going to have waTER
I'm going to have more WA-TER
I am going to have food (again) and.....We'll be good to Go
Ok good enough so we got that
and now I have four of those four LUBES
I've got the computer chip, I've got all that stuff, I've got titanium
what else do I need for a moon pool-
Woah that's a lot of stuff HOOOAH NICE
I like it *trying to sound British*  I like it a lot
I unlocked a lot of upgrades I like it
I Like it A LOT
Ok but I'll need more computer chips once I get that
but I'll worry about that when I get to it
I just want to *with emphasis* BUILD EVERYTHING FIRST
And THEN be good, so I-I GOT EV-ERY-THING (Okay sheesh no need to shout Makimoo)
I've got everything (I think we got that)
I just need to FIND MY god damn GENERAL BOX
so if you could you know COME out of hiding
I didn't put a fucking beacon on ya
*sees box in distance* *shocked* I SEE YOU
Oh I see YOU ok
Now the Generl is just gonna be left alone out here forever (poor Generl)
*singing* Floating a drift in the sea
Never to be seen from again OH WELL
SO SAD
Ok, Is that enough Quartz? I don't think so.
I think I'll need ONE MOAR
IIII-DIM-BER-REA-GLAA-GLEE-GLEE-LEE-LEE-EE (You know what I stopped trying to understand these noises)
DA It's probably enough
OK! HELLO! WELCOME BACK! OK! (We're at the middle of the video Mark)
SO if you have been wondering where we have been all this time
We've been flipping in and out of existence but
now we're good and we're back and we're ready
to make what we need to do I've have literally
all the material necessary to be able to build a base
where I need to build it
and it'll be my PERMANENT deep sea base
that I LOVE and CHARISH and hold very dear
and also it'll be-
AOOH hey it'll be a good launching point
for me to be able to send off
YECH for me to be able to send off..
into the DARK deep depths and also
I know for a FACT there is a entrance-
*fish hits Seamoth* Fucking Stop hitting my god damn Seamoth
I know Woah
I know there's an entrance
into the inactive lava zone FROM
The Deep Reef
I've gone through it I've done it before
I've gone through the deeper areas so I know
for a fact it exists
and so once I build my moon pool and once I able to do all that stuff and-
once I'm able to get my launching point necessary
I will be able to go down deep
into the inactive lava zone
from this point but I have to build a base first
and I'm going to do that I am going to do that if it would stop lagging
and actually get me where I need to go and stop the
*Looks at ceiling* You know OMINOUS DEATH CHOIR
THAT I DON'T ENJOY (who does)
Then I'll be able to do what I need to do.
but until then I am OFF
Where was that platform? Is that the? oh ya that's it OK
this is a good platform I think this is a good launching point for me
*Warning*
Oh that was a new noise. was that a new noise?
Oh that was that was the Sea Treader I remember you
Ok you carry on and be a bag of dicks about everything
I'm gonna build ma base
Ok I've got to get a foundation first PRIME this is everything
If this isn't right then nothing is going to be right
*More markiplier noises* aaand HABOSKEY
ok then we get a multipurpose room
right on the precipice of destruction (lovely name Mark)
and then I'm going to over look the moon pool off on this southern edge
It'll be just like that
MOON POOL oh baby oh baby baby
oh baby baby YES oh baby
Did they make the moon pool bigger? It looks bigger
*high pitched* IT looks a LOT bigger, MAYBE I should move my Seamoth out of the way first
probably a good idea
*Welcome aboard captain*
Thank YOU alright SHABOSKEY
It's a comin'- OHEYOHOY
*More Markimoo noises please stand by*
just that quickly molecular stabilization
I love this tool It's able to re-asign everything for me-
and BOOM oh BABY YEAH
OH HEELL YEAH *louder* OH HELL YEAH
Oh HELL to the YEAH
and I don't think I'll be able to make the Uh
*Warning* I don't think I'll be able to make the uh
the UM-UH
the Uh What should I call it yet
oh its unpowered I forgot to power it (1st unpowered? 2nd really Mark? ¬¬)
'cause I'm a god damn idiot
OH I'm sack of SHIT
Oh but I can build that I can also build the thermal
but I don't know *reads blurb*
I'M GOOD AT THAT *shouts at sky* I've
THIS IS (X2)  Big Blue Ball Barry
Uh Oh thats (X3) Oblong pillar Arnold
Oh Your SPADEFISH SUPER DUPER BOOPER
I'm ABOUT to DIE Ah
NO OXYGEN NICOLAS
alright so I need to get this
place powered
but I don't think a thermal generator will be very good for that
Yeah I'm just going to go with basic POWER
let's just do one of these that's not going to give me anything
Shit well there's basically no way there is power down here
Uh NO I forgot about the hatch (Fucking nailed it Mark *facepalm*)
AAAHH I don't have GLASS
OH *hand tell brain to think* I'm an IDIOT OH FUACK
Oh NO
I guess I can get in this way
*Warning emergency power only-*
Well *-oxygen production offline* well that's (x2) not good
Well there seems to be some oxygen here
Eh It seems to be a little bit It seems to be able to-
It's doing ok It's a struggling a little bit but
you eh know I can forgive it, it's alright
alright so I'm going to have the Fabricator
*high pitched* EH a Ye ye ya
hallway from the moon pool [???]
right there.
there's enough
It's not a lot of power but I mean it's enough
ok so I got that, that's good, I like that, that's good stuff (Snoop Dogg would like it)
like that Great LOVE IT good (What are you Mark a photo shooter?)
The-en I need EEE-EVERYTHING because I have NOTHING
AHAHALA
you know the other challenging thing I need to do is? (nope)
I've gotta walk
or I've gotta swim all the way to my
my (x2) uh
my (x3) uh P.R.A.W.N. suit over there and then I've gotta
walk it all the way back over here Ok alright
I'm back, I'm over here, at my other base
and I have my Buddy BOO over here *Welcome aboard Captain*
Thanks Bob (stands for Bot Of Bashing, not really)
Ugh so hopefully
hopefully (x2)
I'll be able to get this thing back
BUTT what I wanted to do beforehand because I have essentially *welcome aboard Captain*
screwed myself over but that's ok you know it's alright
I didn't say- It's not that bad
It's not that BAD
NOM (X5 fast) Good o'l fruit
so I've got to look and see what I've got in these um... *thinking*
in these inventory places (lockers) and I'm pretty sure
I've got some goodies
So I just need to take the goodies
and utilize the goodies Oh Water HERE who wood hav thunk it
Oh Water HERE who wood hav thunk it
HAHA who'd knew it?
oh whoops didn't mean to do that *warning blood loss detected*
I just drank Water! why did that hurt me?
Fuck You! It's important to note that the solar panels will work
they just won't work well
so I'LL have them
but they won't do a lot so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
disassemble one of these
or deconstruct it because I don't need this much power over
here but I could use the Quartz
and then I'm gonna walk my little guy here all the way over-
to the other place
OH
WOOO I like it (X2) HABOSKEY
get pounchd betches get pounchd oops I get
grabbed apparently
anybody want to get Pounchd
It's weird seeing the ocean from like the floor level
hardly ever I'm able to come do here so I'm just walking through it like this
this is just bizarre
Ooh woah woah
Woah Hello
What's that?
WOAH OK all of a sudden HELLO
How you doin'?
weah (x2) woah (x3) WHEEY woah (x3 *getting softer*)
Wait oh..Ah. LOAD I think (X2) that actually might be
if I'm not-
IT'S a BIOREACTOR HELLLL YEAH
HELLLLLLLL YEEEAAAH
HELL YEAH
I think I need lube for that, but that's not important I got what I got
and I got what I got and that's good
I don't have the space for lube, but I've gotta build lockers first
Oh hello you want to get POUNCHD?
I punch da fuk out oh you
come here get punched bitch
oh yeah that's right RUN AWAY
You don't know what you're up against
It's ME that you're up against
just in case it wasn't obvious
Oh boy (x4) weird seein' you from the bottom oh boy (x3)
ok here we go oh boy
oh boy OH BOY oh boy (x3)
Not used to this ah shit
hoouly fuck
oh apparently it's hot here
ok I need this though
need this (X3)
Ow (x3) It's very hot here well maybe
I can make a- oh I'm right by- Oh maybe
maybe I can make a Thermal Generator woah
Oh WOAH what the fucking fuck
Hello eEEY
WOAH WOAH AHH!
Fuck AH!!
DA FUCK?!?!?
Where'd you put my god damn thing?
da fuck- well that- Where'd it go
DA FUK DID U GO?!
IT'S RIGHT DOWN THERE!!!
*Dying Moose?*
I don't like that (X3) one bit
Heep boop dip
NOT THE STORAGE god dammit
fuck that and fuck that and fuck you
I'm out of here BABY
SHIT I don't where my
base is
but fuck that oh don't go down there or I'll never come back up
thrust make it THRUST BUTTHOLE (that doesn't sound good)
I am lost, I'm scared and I am ALONE
except I'm not alone horrible monstrosity that I believe is the WARPER
that's trying to kill me so that comforting (as comfortable as sleeping in a bed of spikes, rocks and dirt)
I just got to get back here where the illuminated balls are
but I was driven away from the balls
by the son of a bitch
WARPER
Wait I see balls up there so maybe those balls are my ball
I'VE GOTTA FIND MY BALLS (I think they are in your sac Mark)
OH YAY I found IT
oh It took way longer than it should have (much like these subtitles)
but a'lass III- FOund It
and I've brought my monstrosity that is my god damn P.R.A.W.N.
Ok but I don't have a Seamoth so OOPSY DOOPSY POOPSY
HERE we go *more Markimoo noises*
uh ah oh *sounding like Grandma* here's no power
oh I'm fucked
but I got a bioreactor and nothing to build it with
ah you'll just stay
right here and you've got to be getting you
so I'll see you won't I HAHAHAHAHA
I am dying
*Warning Emergency power only. Oxygen production offline
OOOOOO ah ok
I'm a happy guy (of course)
OKAY SO anyway I'm all out of time
I've been playing for about an hour now I have made a couple errors
but hey I've got the MOON POOL (clap clap clap)
IT MAY BE UNPOWERED and I may not have my Seamoth with me
but at least I've got SPIRIT
so that's all that matters, so thank you everybody so much for watching
hope you enjoyed this shit-show of an episode
but I've had some fun
and ran into a new character on the way
so thank you everybody so much for watching and as always
I will see you in the next video
BUH-BYE